Pss,
stay here and get ready to screen
because today
I correct
with you 1 ocean on the environment chapter.
How Kota's resignation markets
do they allow them to deal with
negative externalities
on the environment?
By the way,
don't hesitate to like and subscribe if it helps you,
is the best way to support us.
So already,
you have to define the important terms.
If these are the concepts
of negative externality
and to march from the coast to resign,
1 negative externality,
it is 1 situation in which 1 agent
economic causes
by its activity of negative effects
on the company and in this case
on the environment,
without monetary compensation.
it does not pay for the negative effects of its activity.
Then,
the resigning coast market,
it is also called the market for pollution rights
and it is 1 instrument
used by the public authorities to
combat negative externalities
on the environment.
It consists in setting 1 ceiling
maximum CO 2 emissions
and to distribute a certain number of quotas
corresponding to this objective.
1 rating, this
corresponds to the right to issue 1 certain
amount of gas
with effect of. Certainly,
well,
once you've defined correctly,
you have to explain how this
market works and
allows to face negative externalities
on the environment.
The operation of the
market is based on quota trading between
company. The companies
that put more gas
with circle effect the number of quotas that have been
given,
must purchase.
Quota
additional to companies
that have polluted the least,
1 company exceeds its emission limit,
the bone of coast price at
should encourage it to reduce its emissions
or to invest in technologies
less polluting.
Thus,
the Kota market of issue
allows us to fight against negative eternitys
on the environment by infernalizing the
pollution,
i.e.
by ensuring that companies
take into account in their production moves
the impact of their emissions on the environment
from which the countries.
Here,
I hope it helped you and now you know that.